يقترب السودان من السيناريو الاخطر يتوسع
القتال ويتجاوز القوتين الرئيسيتين الجيش
والدعم السريع فما الذي يجري خارج الخرطوم
في دارفور تسوء الامور على نحو صادم بحسب
نقابه اطباء غرب دارفور تشبه النقابه ما
يجري في ولايه غرب دارفور في مدينه
الجنينه بمجاسر رواندا الاثنيه عام 94
في الجنينه لا يمكن تقديم احصاء دقيق
باعداد الضحايا خلال يومين فقط قتل 800
شخص بينهم اطفال فقدوا حياتهم بسبب الجوع
وبالقياس على الرقم فان الفضاء قد تكون
مروعه الا ان ما يجري في الجنينه تجاوز
حدود حرب البرهان حميدتي تجدد القتال ذو
الطابع القبلي بين القبائل العربيه
والمساليد وهي الاثنيه الافريقيه الغالبه
في الجنينه ما يعيد الى الاذهان القتال
الاعنف بين الطرفين عام 2022 في منطقه
وتعد ولايات دارفور ابرز معاقل قوه الدعم
السريع منذ ان شكلها النظام السابق لقتال
المتمردين
وتسع قوات الدعم السريع للسيطره على اصول
استراتيجيه في دارفور كالممرات الجويه
والطرق الرئيسيه والمناجم ومصادر المياه
ويوصف الاقتتال في دارفور بانه الحرب
الاهليه الافريقيه الاطول ادت الى مقتل
اكثر من 300 الف شخص وتشريد الملايين منذ
عام 2003
ولايه جنوب كردفان بدورها مشتعله قوات
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان شمال
بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو تهاجم وحدات
الجيش السوداني في اربع مناطق وتستولي على
معداتها وتاثر افرادا منها
تتبع القوات المهاجمه لرئيسها عبد العزيز
الحلو رفضت الحركه الانضمام الى اتفاق جبل
السلام الموقع عام 2020 بين الحكومه
الانتقاليه ومجموعه من الحركات المسلحه
لكنها وقعت اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق النار مع
الحكومه الانتقاليه
تسمت العلاقه بين الحلو وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع بالتوتر حتى التقى الرجلان برعايه
سلفا كيرميرديت عام 2020
وثرت انباء انذاك عن دور دوله اقليميه في
الوساطه
[موسيقى]